all show long the co-hosts of queer eye
have been getting me ready for a first
zoom date with a chef named sam who i
met on a dating app this is a true story
and uh we've reached the moment of truth
so
i'm about to log on with sam and
thankfully
the queer eye crew
sticks around with me for at least the
first half of the date they've got cue
cards i can't tell you how fun this is
oh gosh here we go take a look
[Music]
hello sam are you there
i think you're on mute how about now oh
there we go
how are you you look really nice that's
not what this says um tan says to say
that i look cute right oh my god
you do you look amazing you look awesome
so do you so and so do you is your are
there hearts on your sweater yes that's
cute
and um i actually have a first question
which is do you have a favorite book
yeah yeah so my favorite book that i
always go back and i read you know time
after time because i think there's a lot
of lessons in there um is the untethered
soul
i love that book what's going on over
there i see like
[Applause]
i just have my puppies that are sleeping
next to me i don't have
what kind of puppies yeah what kind of
dogs do you have
show your dog
that's santa and tank oh he's hot oh
that's so wonderful i have two dogs
so one of my best friends um
he's a wise man and i'm like dude i
really wish i had you in my ear and
you're doing that for this which is just
i really i love it
maybe we could bring him in next time
and you can have the benefit of such
wise funny voices who ask about x's and
draw eggplants
and um
yeah that's jonathan again of course
open your shirt so we can see your phone
i want to see you today what are your
channels
what do your tattoos mean inappropriate
but i'll show you what are they it's a
triangle
is like you know the blood of um jesus
there's a cross tattooed on my finger
but those things are also they're there
for like inspiration to remind me to be
a better person
i'll date you if she decides
um i have a bird
you both have birds a cross i love you
what he has a great house i do we love
your house oh thanks ask him if he
do you take care of that fiddly fig and
keep it alive or has somebody else
because it looks really good and that
says a lot about you if that's you
taking care of it i have i have a i have
a green thumb i my plants are like mine
likes ferns do you like ferns yeah i
like them all
i was diagnosed with diabetes when i was
12 years old you know you're kind of
forced into responsibility right like
you as an actress at a very young age
you're like forced into this adulthood
at a very good
then i realized from doing different
shows and things that i had this
platform and i could inspire people
through my
illness right and
whether i could give little kids a voice
so maybe if they see someone like me
that can talk about it so freely and can
help them and lead the way like that's
kind of how i've always looked at it you
know it's really good to be authentic
and you know wholesome and and know that
about yourself and not have to like
you know try to be someone you're not
but have fun we love you so much
i've never been able to pretend i'm
someone different i literally will look
at your instagram and be like wow she's
just actually like she says what comes
to her mind you're authentic and you
know you're very beautiful in doing so
and it's just it's it's what people need
and there's so much fake
and so much nonsense you know and
especially in the social world and all
that so when you see someone who's just
like hey look i'm watching my favorite
tv show and i'm like eating a potato
chip and here's what i think about it
it's like oh look we're not looking at
you on a yacht
standing in a bathing suit like drinking
champagne because no one cares i think
growing up in hollywood too
i thought how could i get rid of veneers
this is a job
riddled with them this is a lifestyle
that wants veneers and the more i could
get rid of them and peel away at each
layer throughout every year of my life
and get deeper to the core
that was the mission it's refreshing to
know that like
you're on that
same sort of journey
do you want to play this game and ask
each other a couple questions
it's this gorgeous esther perel game i'm
obsessed with it i like it okay
i have a questionable relationship with
i might watch a little too much
television i get that when i was a kid
and lived on my own my tv was always on
because it made me feel safe so
i think i have a co-dependent
relationship with my television
that's a good answer it's very honest
thank you
an important object i've lost oh god
this is so easy my grandfather's dog tag
from the war and went to cuba
and i went in the ocean and i just saw
it like a wave
like it come off my neck and then just
go into the white water and disappear
forever and i was like no
if there was one place to lose it
the ocean is a poetic place i've
actually never thought about it like
that thank you for saying that because
now i'll look at it and a little bit of
a different light okay last question in
my family
my role is i'm kind of like the
caretaker i just handle it i get it done
wow good
how nice how refreshing
would it be possible to give you my
phone number so that i could actually
have a conversation with you
uh that
was outside of this realm i'd love to
get your phone number
thank you for like
taking this risk because it was just for
fun and to have a good time and not for
tv purposes i've never done this before
and i don't know like i think it's sweet
i also have a really positive
relationship with the camera
it's been in
most of the rooms i've been in my whole
life and it's a friend i love that i
also um just wanted to say you were so
nice and normal when we met on that
dating app that it made me look forward
to meeting you because
there's so much odd behavior in those
scenarios
and you were just so nice so thank you
for being such a lovely human i had a
lot of fun it was really good getting to
know you through our uh
through our favorite game
thank you so much sam speak soon
i mean come on
thank you jonathan tan anthony and bobby
by the way caroma we really missed you
caramel's been on the show several times
and you were here in spirit
i gotta just say
you know um this is about as fun as it
gets in life
when we can be supported
sometimes it is terrifying to go at it
alone
and i didn't have to this time thanks to
them and it did so much for me it is
indescribable
uh by the way sam and i um
did go offline and sent our first tax so
you know
no expectations but
that was so fun and um i gotta tell you
it's my favorite season yet of queer eye
two it's season six it is streaming
right now
on netflix it takes place in austin
it is just as good as it gets whether
it's me or anyone else out there
they are just supporting people in every
single way possible and they just have
all of my admiration and respect what a
dream come true
[Music]